تمثل هذه الإنجازات علامة
فارقة مهمة في أبحاث تكنولوجيا الأونوت
[الموسيقى] التي لا تزال
مكثفة للغاية وهناك تطبيقات
متوقعة أو يتم بحثها بشكل مكثف في
إنتاج الفوتونات للتركيب الكمي
للإلكترونيات المرنة لأجهزة
الاستشعار لتحسين الخلايا الشمسية مما يجعلها
أفضل أو
أرخص.
وعندما أتيت إلى معهد ماساتشوستس للتكنولوجيا، فإن أجواء
معهد ماساتشوستس للتكنولوجيا فريدة حقًا في
العالم، كما تعلمون والتي سمحت
للأبحاث القائمة على الفضول بالازدهار في
بيئة محاطة بالهندسة
المهتمة بالتطبيقات، حيث
يكون رجل الأعمال مهتمًا بنقل
هذه التطبيقات إلى
سوق [الموسيقى]  حسنًا، أعتقد أنه قبل 30 عامًا، لم يكن بمقدور أي
منا ممن بدأوا هذا المجال أن
يتنبأ بعد 30 عامًا بما سنصل إليه
اليوم